so I'm going to give you guys credit I
think it's the um uh the best acting of
both of your careers uh in this film
because um I did notice you were filming
in Atlanta in summer pretending it to be
Christmas thank you man yes 100% you're
very correct uh we were very hot
especially ra I'm sure he can speak on
being in a Santa outfit during the
summertime in Atlanta that is uh
reserves it receives it deserves an
award all by itself yes it was very hot
in that suit I could only use a bath
once a day did you actually gain more
respect for people that are doing
superhero movies with the costumes they
have to wear after doing this 100% I
mean because it's the same thing like
you know because some of those I didn't
do it for me because I didn't want to
deal with it but they'll put like a
cooling thing in there like some people
have like a whole little system inside
of that I didn't know that until I did
saying I'm like wow this is like what
the
Marvel guys go through wearing these
suits all day so yeah I yeah I don't
know I'm I'm proud that I got through it
but it was some hot very sweaty days
yeah honest to God Atlanta in summer
especially August it's like bonus pay
you need because that that is just a
crate anyway so I'm a fan of both of
yours but there's going to be people who
have never seen anything that you've
done so for someone who's never seen
anything you've done before what's the
first thing you want them watching and
why uh dashing through the snow
absolutely uh and and that's so
interesting because this is a holiday
movie so like it is going to be like a
lot of especially a lot of children who
may not know who any of us is and we're
going to be embedded in their heads from
this point on as Santa Claus as Eddie
telling this amazing story that is
filled with heart and it's fun and it's
funny like even watching like we had a
screening yesterday and watching the
children react to the to the different
parts of the movie it was really special
to watch so like I I guess from this
point on I'm probably going to walk the
streets of Santa Claus yeah he said it
best I think there's no greater reward
than being introduced to a whole new
generation of fans that were not there
before you know what I mean you did a
project like this so I think that's
what's exciting about continuing to get
older and and try to own our craft so
for both of you uh when you were looking
at the shoot you see the schedule what's
a day on the schedule that you had
circled either because you were nervous
to film it or because you couldn't wait
to film it uh I was nervous to film a
scene where I actually had to kiss my uh
onscreen uh wife at the time because I
knew that my wife in real life and my
kids were probably going to have some
sort of issue with that and lo and
behold we had a screening last night and
my kids let the entire theater know that
they had a problem with me
kissing my wife on screen so yes that
was a good question oh no you got to get
him back Mama back like what you where's
the Revenge aspect coming from like what
who am I raising right now this that's
the first thing that comes to your mind
is you got to get him back no this is
this is a job this is what's providing
y'all school education right now me
kissing this woman on screen is why you
in school that's so funny you don't need
to get me back now the DAT the thing I
circled on the schedule was the music
number cuz I you know that performance
that was a lot so uh that was that the
first time we did that uh which is why I
circled it cuz I'm like this is what you
going to get this this day you gonna get
everything there you go that's
it one of the things though about this
uh uh because it's going to be on Disney
plus is you do not uh you don't have to
worry about the opening weekend box
office numbers uh like is that nice as
an actor to not have to worry about the
box office or is there is there an
element that you you know what I mean
yeah I actually wish this was in
theaters so that we could look forward
to the weekend box office numbers I know
so many people that around this time
they're literally wanting to jump
straight into the holiday season and I
feel like we have something special
because it really breaks away from the
norm of all Christmas movies that I've
ever experienced or seen so it would
have been interesting but at the end of
the day we're not complaining at all
we're thankful for whatever you know we
have and to be on a platform like Disney
plus come on now that's that's
everyone's dream and I I love that it's
streaming too I mean like the box office
is so tricky now and you know the and we
just got off strike so you know if you
can't you know as you can see like some
of some of other movies had a hard time
because they wasn't able to promote it
right and so like you know honestly this
is weirdly perfect timing for us to be
able to promote this movie and it's
coming on Disney plus but I this would
have been interesting to watch cuz even
watch it in the theaters and the screen
it would have been been fun cuz I think
it is a theater movie cuz it is a big
Christmas movie and there's all these
great things happening uh but no Disney
Plus thank you we fine just watch it
let's just make those streaming numbers
go crazy there is a world where if this
movie does well and people continue to
watch it after every Christmas there
could be a select limited run in the
future of theaters we need you guys to
make that happen so one of the things uh
that I really am happy about
representation matters and honestly
there's not too many times where there's
a black Santa Claus in a movie often
it's portrayed by white people and uh
I'm just curious if you could talk a
little bit about that the importance of
representation and being able to play
Santa it's um it's it's a dream come
true to play Santa and it's so important
just to see it's not even just for our
culture and just for black people to see
a black Santa but other cultures to see
that Santa Claus and other characters
which you know not even just from you
know even when you see a Little Mermaid
and black like we just it's I don't
think we should should have ever put a
race on characters like anybody should
be able to play anybody you know what I
mean like if if you know that's what I
love about you know this the Spider-Man
uh world with they with they mouths you
know I like that's what it should be
these are just characters so it should
never be tied to a race you know and so
like to be to be a black Santa it's a
beautiful thing and you know I I
hopefully I I I get a chance to be in
those long lines of sant where I'm I'm a
memorable one because of because of that
white and black
beard Chris I'm curious uh uh this is
going to switch to something else but
I'm obviously a fan of a certain
franchise that's out a lot of movies and
uh last time I spoke to Vin he told me
he knows how it all ends has Vin shared
with you how it all ends or is he sort
of like I'll tell you when we're filming
the last one no he has not shared with
me these are things that everyone has to
keep tight lift about because if you saw
fast X it's open-ended so yes you are
correct and I don't blame you for for
wanting to know but I can honestly tell
you I'm not hiding anything from you or
being political I don't really know how
it ISS there's so many characters and so
many different things that have to
synchronize and come together in order
to make this the best ending that we
could possibly make it for this
franchise to do it justice that there's
nothing I can tell you right now that's
crazy yeah the thing about it is I'm a
fan of Louie and I uh he did a miracle
with the last one I love love drink oh
I'm sorry go ahead what I was dring like
do you actually know when you're filming
the last one has anyone said anything or
is it just a hope for NE early next year
it's too early to tell because both
these strikes just ended so no one has
said anything as of yet my man I was
just gonna say uh for both of you guys
um uh is there a holiday film that you
always like to watch at Christmas time
or in the holidays I should say is there
one that always oh for me National
Lampoon Christmas Vacation bro I can
watch that over and over over again man
Chevy Chevy
Chase oh my goodness it's a wonderful
life is is just a forever class it's
such a really good you know what's funny
it's so many different times I've watch
I watched it from enjoying it as a fan
and then now being like a person who's
in the film and like it's such a perfect
movie it's a perfect movie so yeah it's
a wonderful life on that note gentlemen
thank you so much for your time I hope
it's a huge hit and good luck with the
rest of your speed dating thank
you I like that that's
all